now if you've been following American
politics over the past nine months or so
and you have a decently functioning
human brain you should not have been
surprised to wake up to the news that
Rex Tillerson is out at the State
Department Rex and I have been talking
about this for a long time we we got
along actually quite well but we
disagreed on things when you look at the
Iran deal I think it's terrible I guess
he fit it was okay I wanted to either
break it or do something and he felt a
little bit differently so we were not
really thinking the same Tillerson who
was told he was being let go on Friday
by General Kelly spoke briefly to
reporters today and he didn't look well
he was visibly emotional I want to speak
now to my State Department colleagues
and to our interagency colleagues and
partners at DoD and the Joint Chiefs for
staffs most particularly to my foreign
service officers and civil service
colleagues we all took the same oath of
office whether your career employee or
political point D we are all bound by
that common commitment well that was
nice
well back in November I asked the
president about the Secretary of State's
job security
I want my vision but my vision is my
vision anyway it's called cost saving
there's nothing wrong with cost saving
rex is in there working hard he's doing
his best he's doing the best of being
with you for the duration well we'll see
I don't know who's gonna be well not
exactly a ringing endorsement of the
duration well of course the lemmings in
the press spent the entire day painting
the Tillerson firing as evidence of more
White House dysfunction this almost
feels like a vacation from the reality
TV style turmoil that is turning back at
Washington the president may be
wondering why didn't come to California
sooner this is his first trip out here
because it
that he's left behind what does chaos
mean in our foreign policy it means many
of our allies who I've worked for over
the years they don't know what to expect
next from the United States that creates
a vacuum in the world that Russia is
moving into very quickly
and China is moving into in Asia oh yeah
Trump caused the rise of China and in
the Russia aggression and Crimea oh my
goodness chaos you mean what we saw for
the eight years of the Obama
administration when Barack Obama didn't
fire anyone over Benghazi the IRS
targeting of conservatives or the Fast &
Furious scandal or was it the chaos we
saw when Obama pushed out Qaddafi and
Mubarak sparking the rise of Isis in
Iraq and in Syria now what about the
chaos of doubling our debt and exploding
the trade deficit as China of course
grew bolder and more powerful did any of
that count as chaos well Trump by
contrast has been very clear that we
want to have better relationships with
more nations if possible and we're not
gonna be anyone's pushover look the fact
is Tillerson should have tendered his
resignation a long time ago he disagreed
with the President on major issues he
was opposed to the talks with North
Korea he supported the Paris climate
Accords he questioned the president's
charlottesville response he was at odds
with Trump on moving the US embassy to
Jerusalem and was a fan of the Iran
nuclear deal
oh great president of course was not a
fan other than that the two were
perfectly in sync and then there was
this address that the main headline of
this story that you called the president
a [ __ ] and if not where do you think
these reports are I'm not going to deal
with petty stuff like that I mean this
is this is what I don't understand about
Washington again you know I'm not from
this place but the places I come from we
don't deal with that kind of petty
nonsense the place I come from is if you
call your boss a [ __ ] you probably
shouldn't be in that position the only
question I have is why did it take the
president so long to fire
Tillerson I'm sure he's a nice guy but
come on CIA director Mike Pompeo by all
accounts is a far better fit to be Trump
Secretary of State as the president said
it's kind of about chemistry and
approach Tillerson didn't gel in either
category I've gotten to know a lot of
people very well over the last year and
I'm really at a point where we're
getting very close to having the cabinet
and other things that I want and since
last summer the president has been
slowly getting his team together think
about it
he hired General John Kelly his chief of
staff he moved Sarah Sanders and his
press secretary
he moved Tom price out and Alexei czar
in as Secretary of HHS and I'm sure
there's gonna be a lot more changes to
come
that's not chaos that's called smart
staffing he's been in the White House
just over 13 months or so and now Trump
knows what he needs and his closest
staff in the cabinet too and he might
not do everything the button-down
traditional way well that's for sure but
he's hitting his stride and he's getting
a really strong team in place think
about it this way when a player isn't
performing on the field or on the court
a good coach benches him and when that
same player is a consistent drag on the
team well a good coach is gonna treat
him or just let him go entirely and
that's precisely what Trump did and he
should do the same with anyone else who
seems pain to support his agenda once he
makes his decision final and that's the
angle